mom why did you choose this life I
didn't really choose this life it chose
me
I put the picture of me and you there so
that all my siblings can say I'm your
favorite for my entire adult life I've
been two steps behind you with this
camera trying to keep up with you I am a
Workhorse and a show horse I was born
into a family that was fiercely
patriotic and staunchly Democratic
politics was the life that we met I have
the high privilege as the first
president to begin the State of the
Union message with these words
Madam speaker
[Applause]
good job
[Music]
some people count cheap at night I count
votes I cannot take a bill to the floor
with this in it this is you know back
door way for something that I said we
could not cross the threshold here's
what happens in negotiations you can't
get tired you can never get tired you're
gonna be on your best behavior tonight
yes I am don't do anything I wouldn't do
thank you very much
why did you tear it up with a total pack
of rice
let us pray that today January 6th it
will be an epiphany for the American
people
look at the protesters outside the
capitol
oh my God how did
we go
Mr Vice President don't let anybody know
where you are we always knew that this
responsibility would take us into the
night we'll stay as long as it takes
I'm going to call the house to order I
hope that it stays in order if it
doesn't stay in order I'll call it to
order again
you're always on message there's no
cracking you huh well then that's what
you want to do crack your mom
yes I do I want to crack you